Bonjour! Bienvenue dans ce troisième épisode
de Gentes Dames Badass dans lequel nous nous
intéresserons à une femme bien puissante
du XVIe siècle. J'ai nommé: Marguerite
d'Autriche.
Ouais, encore quelqu'un de riche et noble.
J'aimerais pouvoir vous présenter des femmes
qui ont fait des choses formidables sans être
de haute naissance, mais surtout au Moyen-Âge,
c'est compliqué et les sources nous ont surtout
laissé les traces des gens importants. C'est
dommage.
Mais tant pis, je serai le Stéphane Berne
de youtube cet été: parlons de Marguerite
d'Autriche.
Quand j'ai découvert sa vie j'ai été impressionnée
par deux choses: son habileté politique
doublée d'une malchance en amour, c'est pas
possible d'avoir un aussi mauvais karma.
Marguerite d'Autriche, ou de Habsbourg naît
donc le 10 janvier1480 à Bruxelles, et est
la petite-fille de Charles le Téméraire!
C'était pas vraiment du Chroniques de Prof
si je casais pas le nom d'un duc de Bourgogne
à un moment donné.
Du coup sa mère, c'est Marie de Bourgogne,
et son père c'est l'empereur Maximilien Ier.
Il possède pas mal de territoires.
A trois ans, Marguerite est fiancée et directement
conduite chez son futur époux, qui est aussi
le futur roi de France Charles VIII, et qui
a huit ans de plus qu'elle donc on va attendre
un peu avant de les marier. Elle est donc
élevée en France mais en 1491, quand Marguerite
a 11 ans, son fiancé la répudie. Il préfère
épouser Anne de Bretagne, et elle rentre
donc chez son père avec sa dot et un premier
mariage raté.
C'est que le début: à la fin de l'année
1496, elle fait route vers l'Espagne parce
que comme le roi de France l'a grave insultée,
son père décide de se rapprocher des rois
d'Espagne. Elle épouse donc à 16 ans Jean
d'Aragon, héritier des royaumes de Castille
et d'Aragon, et c'est le grand amour: elle
l'aime, il l'aime, tout va bien jusqu'à ce
que son mari décède de maladie en 1497.
Six mois après le mariage. Et Marguerite
était enceinte, mais fait une fausse couche.
En 1500 elle rentre à Bruxelles, elle a seulement
20 ans et a déjà failli se marier deux fois
mais finalement non.
Jamais deux sans trois!
Son troisième mari,qu'elle épouse en 1501,
est Philibert II, duc de Savoie. On baisse
un peu en prestige mais ils sont heureux ensemble,
ils chassent, font la fête, et surtout Philibert
lui confie la gestion des affaires du duché,
ce qui lui permet de révéler des talents
politiques certains! Et forcément, elle
garde une petite rancœur envers les français
et oriente la politique du duché vers la
maison de Habsbourg, sa maison.
Mais en 1504, trois ans après le mariage,
son mari meurt d'un accident de chasse. Et
elle refait une fausse couche. Ça commence
à être dur. Elle fait édifier le monastère
de Brou à la mémoire de Philibert, et rentre
chez elle.
Elle a 24 ans, et elle commence à saturer
alors quand son père tente de la remarier
elle dit stop et se consacre à partir de
là à d'autres activités: le mécénat,
parce que ses deux mariages l'ont rendue bien
riche, et la politique.
Dans sa cour, à Malines, elle reçoit des
écrivains comme Erasme, des musiciens comme
Josquin des Près, ou encore des peintres,
et passe beaucoup de commandes d'art. Elle
peut, elle est riche.
Par ses fiançailles avec Charles VIII elle
a gagné les comtés d'Artois, d'Auxerre,
de Bourgogne, de Charolais, de Mâcon... Par
son mariage en Castille, elle reçoit un revenu
de vingt-mille écus par an et par son dernier
mariage elle a douze-mille écus par an grâce
aux comtés de Bâgé, de Romont et de Villar.
Au niveau politique, en 1507 elle devient
régente des Pays-Bas pour son neveu, le futur
Charles Quint, qui a alors 6 ans.
Elle met aussi en place des alliances politiques
en Europe, souvent contre la France. Elle
est remerciée par Charles en 1515 lorsqu'il
demande son émancipation mais il la rappelle
finalement en 1519 au moment de son accession
au trône: chez les Habsbourg, la transmission
de la couronne impériale se fait par élection
donc c'est le plus populaire qui gagne. Et
comme sa tante Marguerite connaît tout le
monde, elle a vite fait de le faire empereur
et récupère le gouvernement des Pays-Bas
au passage.
En 1529 elle signe la paix des Dames qui règle
les conflit entre François Ier et Charles
Quint: elle représente alors Charles Quint,
avec Marie de Luxembourg, sa cousine, et Louise
de Savoie représente son fils François Ier.
Et c'est aussi l'ex-belle sœur de Marguerite,
puisque c'était la sœur de Philibert avant
de devenir la mère de François Ier, vive
les histoires de famille.
Finalement elle meurt de la gangrène en 1530,
après une vie bien remplie.
Et pour finir, Marguerite d'Autriche avait
pris pour devise Fortune Infortune Fort Une,
qui en plus d'être une belle polyptote ne
veut pas dire grand chose tout seul mais semble
montrer qu'elle a connu la fortune, l'infortune,
et qu'elle est restée forte. Si vous êtes
curieux, on trouve sur Gallica une notice
explicative sur cette devise qui tente d'en
comprendre le sens, que je vous met dans la
description.
A dans deux semaines pour la dernière gente
dame badass de l'étéet n'oubliez pas:
fortune infortune fort une !